well hello you guys so it is obvious the
energy and the friendship between you
two
what was it like working together it's
just a pleasure for me yeah huge but
yeah yeah it was it was I loved how I
love that you love being an actor oh I
hope this doesn't sound like a
left-handed compliment but like you
don't play it cool about being an actor
like you were just always so
enthusiastic and excited to be there and
I'm that way too so I just say so I'm
just like oh good thank God we can both
be thrilled and to create from that
place of just being so happy and
grateful and yeah and and fulfilled by
this opportunity you know it's
impossible to be around you and not want
to emulate your accent American accent
actually likes really deeply impressive
thank you like I say before and it's got
like I was impressed and she's got some
once in London slang down I usually meet
people they say the cockney thought they
watch Mary Poppins they start quoting
that but I'm like you some like current
daily London slang like and it's a cool
chick
oh very cool literally I've never heard
that before so thank you very very much
congratulations by the way that is so
exciting I mean that is it is it's
really exciting yeah and I love that you
I feel like every time we see you you're
always saying something that's
self-aware that's mindful that's
inclusive and I know you said it even
just in your baby announcement that
other people go through struggles and
it's okay and I really like that thank
you very much I really dig it let's talk
about modern love because that's another
thing that you guys brought like to
mental health why did you want to be a
part of this episode in particular oh
well I mean I I actually wasn't familiar
with the column that
this anthology is based on so that's got
a real pleasure to discover but I just
wanted to work with John Carney I wanted
to work with him for about a decade and
so we've been trying to find the right
thing he would email each other he would
be directing this project or and I'd ask
him to director project nothing ever
worked out and then this one came came
along I was really special for me
it was really special for me and I and I
could think of a lot of people in my
life who would who would feel seen by
this episode and that was important to
me too mm-hmm and then I found out Gary
was doing it and I was like very sad but
for me like that was I was parking out
because I'm sex with a sign but like
being a fan of film um I'm like a
massive fan of fans but even from like
very early projects like I've been a fan
forever and um so I mean working with
John as well that was a highlight yeah
and and the topic the theme as well but
I think the script I mean it approaches
it like a slight sensitive Izzie yeah um
content was like it's really great so
I'm not super excited to be part of it
yeah did you get to choose which story
which love story you wanted to tell
because I know each episode is a
different modern love story did you have
to pick this particular episode this was
the one that John sent and and so I just
yeah so I was this was I was so happy
because this is the one I think now
having seen them with respect to all the
other ones this is the one I would have
chosen mmm interesting I like that
one of the things that I really enjoyed
was the singing and dancing did you guys
have fun with that I I got to watch it
like there's so many things you wouldn't
know from watching it like how I spoke
about it before like how freezing it was
that day I mean I know it like you
Canadians are probably like was it cold
but it actually was like Canadians would
have thought it was cold
that's how cold it was yeah it was
because we had a cold snap temperature
dropped we were filming right next to
the water so we had the cold air coming
in from the water and it was
hurricane-force winds and it was a dance
sequence so none of us could you know we
were filming in fairly light clothing
I'm doing the best we could we could
only shoot two takes at a time before
everybody would kind of freeze up and
you couldn't actually move and we'd have
to run inside and get warm so I just
have to like shout out to all the
dancers that day not a complaint out of
any of them their energy was amazing
every single take it wouldn't have
happened without them they were
brilliant yeah machines yeah one of my
favorite moments was well there's too
much fear moments but one of them was
you in the bathroom breaking down
because I never really realized what it
would be like for someone to be bipolar
and go through the you know excited
manic point and then realize that you
can't actually continue your day and
seeing you go through that was wild and
then the moment where you were
disappointed waiting for her to come out
of the room so what is just your
relation to mental health like how do
you relate to this I think my
relationship with mental health is
getting better all the time you know I
think the world's relationship with it
is getting better all the time I keep
thinking about this concept that we we
inherit are the previous generations
hopelessness the things that they
couldn't quite for whatever reason
because they inherited the previous
generations hopelessness and the things
that
they couldn't crack and we look at it
and for whatever reason we were born
with the ability to try it out in a
different way and I think mental health
is something that we're doing better I
do I think that we're releasing our
shame we're releasing our stigma
we're digging down and finding the
courage to be open about it you know I
think that a lot of people are coming
forward and saying this thing that has a
lot of silence around it this thing is
my life
yeah and rather than have it be defined
by people who don't have it let me tell
you what it's like and I and I think the
key for our generation now in all
aspects not just with mental health but
with so many issues is to learn how to
listen and to learn how not to chime in
with our opinions about what someone
else's experience might be having like
that might be happening and maybe not
learn how to comment so quickly but
actually just sit and hold space and
listen and make someone else who's going
through a hard time feel seen and feel
safe
yeah you have a relation to it as well
Oh understanding it or yeah I mean it's
everyday sanitation for me just like I
said I'm really enjoying and loving the
fact that there's so much more humanity
humanity sir like this so much more
humanity evolved and on like to see the
breakdown of all the preconceptions you
know a lot of us have had and on the
education that's so important yeah and
the breakdown of the stigmas as well
it's all it's so really that's why I'm
really proud to be part of this project
and I think the show represents that so
well and contribute to that in a really
great way yeah there's one part in it
where you have a dating profile and you
write Who am I have you ever thought
about that and what you'd have to put in
your dating profile I think I'm actually
hard I think I'd have to put not who you
think you know you know because I think
a lot of people and to be fair what how
could they not we you know there's been
they might have an opinion of Who I am
before they meet me and I think I'm
different than the more people imagine
so I think that would probably be mine
yeah but that's an but I'm not sure
everybody could leave with that I think
that might one might be unique no idea
what I mean
such that um I don't do the whole dating
app thing list off I have no idea what I
would even put in my profile I think
it's really hard to say who you like who
only yeah like that's why it's hard it's
hard yeah um I have no idea no dating
apps a no grocery store peach situation
happening in your life I don't have me
cute like the highways I'm pretty fine
with going up to people I think are fine
but I've been married I don't know very
happy committed relationship her list
for 11 years but no I was a I didn't
struggle with that
yes absolutely yeah yeah I seem sweet
that's what I mean don't you don't I'm
not who you think I am I seem sweet but
but I I know how to
I know what I like and I go after it
again as a cool chick and lastly how
would you define modern laughs I've been
thinking about so Daniel the editor of
the anthology and the you know the
column the podcasts everything he talked
about it in a panel that we were doing
and he and the way he said modern it
just and he's really smart and kind of a
you know deeply impressive so I was
thinking about it like modern love
modern art and I was thinking about that
Hannah Gatsby Netflix special in the net
where she kind of describes modern art
and how Pablo Picasso is the you know
kind of the grandpa the Godfather of it
because he's the one that released us
from a single perspective he showed us
that all perspectives were possible and
I just thought about that definition of
modernity is being tied to an infinite
number of perspectives and I thought
that's modern love because for his many
mmmm as many of us as there are a
therapy polier I've got just just
cheering to the right side he'll if
there's a whole crew all of us that
there are there's as many different
perspectives on love yeah and so I think
that and there's many different nuanced
stories about it and and specifics and
that's why I think it's an inexhaustible
subject and that to me is kind of what
what modern love is and how that takes
form and thank God hopefully it's going
to become even more open and even more
inclusive and we'll get more
perspectives and it'll become more
nuanced and we'll all become more
sensitive and all the bad things will go
away
now the accent attached to this humanity
linked to human you got it I would say
on definitely that sense of freedom I
say is that more than love I guess so I
mean I think that's what all their free
time till I achieve together like as a
collective and um yeah I think the show
definitely represents that and that's
that's amazing
that's you